we need more of you on screen so I have  to ask about two upcoming projects of  course euphoria season two I'm freaking  out about it are we gonna get more of  you in season two yes yes yeah right  answer Gia's becoming her own person and  she's getting her own storyline which is  very exciting so I'm excited to start  that very soon so you start shooting it  soon as we start shooting season two  very soon that is so exciting good luck  with that thank you so I don't know if  you've already shot your bit of Suicide  Squad but James Gunn is another one of  my favorite directors out there he's  incredible like the nicest person but  also SuperDuper talented and I have  filmed my my piece in Suicide Squad too  so I can't wait to see that all come  together and I was a fan of the  franchise before so now to be a part of  it is really cool